director Joss Whedon blew the doors off
the superhero movie world would be
Avengers but his follow-up Avengers age
of Ultron kind of left a few things to
be desired from weird plot points the
mysterious helicarrier's that pop up
right when you need them here are a few
of the dumb things about Avengers age of
Ultron everyone just ignored why is
stark still Iron Man before age of
Ultron the last time we saw Tony Stark
was in a solo flick Iron Man 3 stark
spends most of that film dealing with
the post-traumatic stress from the alien
invasion in the Avengers he eventually
realizes he doesn't need the armor and
walks off into the sunset with Pepper
Potts nice great ending so long Tony
so then why it's Tony flying around in a
shiny new suit when age of Ultron rolls
around we never get an answer any age of
Ultron basically ignores all the
character development and growth that we
saw in Iron Man 3 why well probably so
he can go and make the movie villain by
accident
speaking of which Tony Stark
is wildly irresponsible Ultron might get
top billing
but seriously Tony Stark is the real
villain of this movie he tinker's with
technology and magic he doesn't
understand and then just sets the whole
thing to run on autopilot so he can go
party and then he said how surprised
when an evil AI is born from the
all-powerful infinity stone even worse
when Captain America calls him out on
his idiocy
he gets all defensive and shifts the
blame sure his intentions may have been
noble but building some fail-safes into
his insanely dangerous experiments might
have been even nobler or at least run
some antivirus software something dude
missing and in action the big party
scene early in the run time was one of
the best moments in this film serving is
a fun reminder that this is a big
expansive universe but where did Falcon
and more machine' disappear to when the
action started at least war machine
shows up right at the end the Falcon is
still nowhere to be found
wouldn't having an extra flying guy be
useful during this gigantic battle that
threatened an entire city and it'd be
one thing if these characters hadn't
showed up early on come on they're
already in the movie
what could Falcon possibly have had to
do that be more important than helping
save the entire freakin world
we have ability to Christine
oh well never mind what the Helicarrier
in Captain America the Winter Soldier
cap forces shield helicarrier's to blow
themselves up and then the whole shield
organization disband but right when the
Avengers need it most
boom a Helicarrier comes out of nowhere
to save the day
that's not only really convenient it
also makes no sense
the Helicarrier was eventually explained
away in an episode of Marvel's agents of
shield but expecting people to watch a
supplemental video to explain the plot
contrivance is of Avengers age of Ultron
is even dumber than this random
Helicarrier couldn't they have found
some other way to get around you know I
have the authority to downgrade jazz to
a Winnebago I'm aware of that sir logic
buster fans have been clamoring for a
straight-up Iron Man vs. Hulk fight ever
since the MCU became a thing in age of
Ultron delivered in spades thanks the
Iron Man Hulkbuster armor which is so
powerful it allows Tony to go toe-to-toe
with a big green guy awesome right but
if the Hulkbuster armor is dat amazing
why doesn't he just use it all the time
it seems silly to develop something this
awesome and only use it for this one
specific fight you know maybe the crazy
powerful Hulkbuster armor could have
come in handy when the Avengers had to
battle a certain murderous robot trying
to destroy the world speaking of which
Ultron's dumb plan so Ultron is an
infinitely advanced AI with a bloodlust
he wants to take out the Avengers and
also all of humanity hey go big or go
home right he quickly lets loose inside
the internet and though we're told he
can't access the nuclear launch codes
thinks Jarvis fighting him off there's
still a lot of other things he could
mess with how about the electrical grid
the water supply the fuel supply traffic
lights air traffic controllers why not
hijack every piece of tech used by the
Avengers and turn it against them the
list goes on but instead of causing
global panic and making toasters kill
people Ultron decides to build a
humanoid super body recruit a couple of
freaky super rave kids to help them
fight and then drop a city on the
Avengers that
seems needlessly complicated and stupid
what's the vibranium for I'm glad you
asked that because I wanted to take this
time to explain my evil plan
look Ultron you may be like a super
genius robot guy or whatever but when
your plan is officially dumber than the
plot of Maximum Overdrive you messed up
thanks for watching click the looper
icon to subscribe to our YouTube channel
let's check out all this cool stuff we
know you'll love to
[Music]